les plaques de la croûte terrestre lls
un peu coincé donc se déforme
difficilement et cette convergence de
deux plaques va induire de la
déformation de la plaque supérieure à
plaque eurasienne
mais donc on fabrique des chaînes de
montagne on comprime la croûte terrestre
on fabrique berline en fait les deux
plaques elle frotte elles sont coincées
donc pendant que ça pousse derrière
l'abbaye si ça coince à s'accumuler à un
moment la croûte dépasse le seuil de
résistance et lâche et donc leurs
produits alimentaires qui permet le
relâchement de la tension accumulée sur
les plaques de force
sas a produit le tremblement de terre le
dernier séisme géant au népal remonte à
1934 8,3 sur l'échelle de richter en
yann klinger et son équipe publie une
étude selon laquelle le séisme de 1934
serait annonciateur d'un autre séisme
imminent sur cette faille l'histoire va
leur donner raison
[Musique]
le 25 avril 2015
un tremblement de terre de magnitude 7,9
sur l'échelle de richter frappe le népal
sur plus de 200 km de part et d'autre de
la capitale katmandou
je mets tant d'énergie dans system un
séisme de magnitude 7,2 de magnitude 8
va libérer à peu près autant donc
aujourd'hui où est-ce qu'on a libéré ou
est-ce qu'on n'a pas libéré
donc quelles sont les zones qui ont
besoin de libérer quelles sont les zones
qui ont moins besoin de libérer en
faisant ce travail on avait
effectivement pointé la zone qui a rompu
comme étant une des zones qui étaient
prêtes à certaines zones de l'himalaya
comme la zone de jeux sonores de
katmandou et menthe et de presque d'un
mètre en à peu près une minute en fait
puisque le tremblement terre
durée 2 lors de la minute dans d'autres
zones
paradoxalement l'himalaya est un peu
descendu par exemple les plus hauts
sommets de l'himalaya sont momentanément
descendu un petit peu
au dessus de l'épicentre les villages de
pierre sont totalement rasée par la
violence du choc qui tue une centaine
d'habitants les survivants sont réduits
à l'errance
je m'appelle quand jigoro j'ai tout
perdu maisons et même quand la terre a
tremblé
je préparais la fête de la pleine lune
je faisais chauffer comme maintenant de
l'alcool de riz à l'avenir qu'on appelle
ici le rac chi autour de moi dans le
village tout a brûlé
tout s'est écroulé on a eu peur des
répliques
alors on s'est réfugié dans les champs
après le tremblement de terre on est
resté trois jours dans les champs avec
les animaux sans manger
heureusement des amis des autres
villages sont arrivés avec des habits et
de la nourriture
aujourd'hui on n'a plus rien mais il
faut bien continuer à vivre maintenant
on vit là haut dans les pâturages dans
un camp de maisons construites à la hâte
avec des bâches ce ne sont que des abris
temporaires mais je ne sais pas où nous
habiterons demain
[Musique]